[Music]
run when you can walk if you have to and
crawl if you must that's pretty much
what I have learned from running
marathons and that's the approach to my
life I try to give my best at everything
I do the artificial intelligence and
machine learning program by celtech
offered by simply learn was an enriching
experience for me I've already started
applying the learnings at my work in the
areas of development and automation hi
I'm rupam Chopra and I live in guro I'm
a computer engineer I started working
around 19 20 years ago I started working
in the uh Olden era of dialup Internet
working through the technical landscape
now I'm working as a vice president in
an organization as I decided to take my
career to the next level I started
researching for programs in artificial
intelligence and machine learning that's
when I came across the AIM ml program by
Caltech which was offered by simply
learn based on my research by far this
has been the best program that I could
have had and it was a truly enriching
and profoundly fulfilling experience
overall it's an excellent program by
itself some of the features of this
program that I really liked first was
the accessibility that the program is
available on all devices web mobile the
second feature I really liked is the
comprehensive training material you have
books references and the third best
thing about this is the labs the
practice Labs that you can access from
anywhere about leveraging the knowledge
that I have learned in this program I've
already started applying it we are
working in the areas of development test
automation test data application where
machine learning models are being built
I am writing a book which is due to
publish in a couple of months which is
particularly about the Doha of s Kabir
where I'm interpreting the doas in
English and interestingly I have taken
the help of uh my computer background
the technical background and artificial
intelligence and machine learning you
have got only one life live it to the
fullest and give it the
best